The book is outstanding and you know it's,
it's,
it's more than just sitting with like
sitting across from you and you telling
your story is one thing,
but this long detailed history of how
you became to be the person you became.
I think it's very educational for
people because they can realize like,
oh, he wasn't always this guy. Right?
This is what's fucked up about people.
Like you see a guy who's
like you, who runs, I mean,
how many ultra marathons did you run
in a row? You've ever had some insane,
I read 808 weekends in a row to stop and
think about that ladies and gentlemen.
Eight hundreds means eight 100 mile races,
eight weekends in a row,
a hundred mile race will put you out
for fucking six months, right? You know,
and you rent eight of them,
eight weekends or it's a fuck.
It's a fucking insane accomplishment.
It was nuts.
You think about a person like that,
you think of them as in this like static,
fully formed version.
You don't usually get to see,
and especially someone like you who you
went into so much depth about your rise
and fall and rise and fall.
It wasn't like a straight linear process
between you getting inspired and then
you becoming this bad motherfucker. No, it
wasn't like, um, what's that show called?
Um,
that will Smith plays that,
that black guy who kind of makes
it in, um, in the financial world,
a pursuit of happiness. I never
saw that. Yeah, it's a great movie.
It wasn't like pursuit
of happiness, man. Like,
like with a guy who struggles and he,
and he gets over it and he makes it,
I fell on my ass.
I thought I'd got the top of Mount
Everest and Mont Everest just fucking sly
right underneath me, man. I was like,
God, dog. I start from scratch again.
Scratch became my friend, literally.
Man. So, you know, that's the,
that's how we put in the book
match. Going up, going down,
going up just to real raw
version of how my life was in.
It was so in depth to go back through
your life with a fine tooth comb that I
almost got embarrassed. Even put
it out there to people. Yeah,
that'd be north damn man.
Like even me right now to talk to you.
I'm in the car for a fucking hour
getting pumped up because I'm a shy
introverted leave me alone type of guy.
Like I'm still that motherfucker
who is six years old,
you know at a play who can't say as line
because I know I'm going to stutter in
front of five people. So I walk
off the stage. That's still me.
So everyday I'm fighting that dude.
So people think, oh my God, man,
you in a pod case looks
so crazy, so evil. No,
I'm trying to be locked into Joe so my
mind isn't veer off saying let's run out
the damn door because people are
watching me on the fucking podcast. Oh,
won't open it damn door and get the hell
out of here man. So that's the real me.
So I'm not sadistic man.
I'm focused on what I have to do to
stay locked into the game of life.
And that's what, and that's why I tell
people, man, I go there, I go there.
That's one of the reasons why this book
is so good is because you're so honest
about your vulnerabilities
and how you overcome them.
And for people that see someone who's
a beast, who's done great things,
you just assume that they're
different than you, right?
But then you hear about your insecurities
and your pitfalls and all the things
that went wrong with you,
and you realize what God dammit,
those the same things
that go wrong with me.
Like maybe I have that inside of me
and I've just never summoned it. Right.
And I'll tell you this,
I started really realizing that
when I started overcome myself,
I started getting around these real
alpha males, these hard, hard men.
And I always put people way above me
when I was growing up like my God,
they had to have a lot more than
me to get to where they're at.
And a lot of them did.
But once you get around the,
the best of the best of the best people,
you can kind of start breaking
them down. And realizing, man, you,
you're just as fucked up as
me. Like, like we all have.
But all you did was you hit it
better. Your, your, your upbringing,
your mom and dad, your society,
the way you were raised,
it hit it better than the mine.
You weren't the only black kid or there
was like five a in a school, you know,
I can't hide going through buds.
I was the only black kid you can't hide.
But I started realizing just
because I look different than you,
a lot of you must first can hot either.
So it started giving me courage through
watching people that were all have a
story. We all have a jacked
up life in one way or another.
Some of us don't have the
guts to talk about it though.
And that's where I found
the guts to talk about mine.
Well there's some does purity
in physical pursuits, right?
Because it doesn't matter
what your social status is.
It doesn't matter how people
perceive you. When, uh,
when it comes down to how long can you
stay in that pool when it comes down to
how far can you run,
when it comes down to how much can you
push yourself past the part where you
want to quit or how far can
you keep going? There's a
purity in that that it did,
did dissolve social order,
all that bullshit,
all the what people think about you goes
out the window. It's what, who will,
who are you right now? Cause right boy
you right now that's a true statement man.
And I look at his size as psychological
warfare and that's where I started
learning that that life is one big
psychological warfare that you play on
yourself. You play on yourself. Man.
The most important conversation
ever had my is with myself.
And the Shit I was telling myself
was so fucked up. It was so wrong.
It was so misguided.
And other people start to write that down.
Luck for you also and start to be what
you say to yourself every single day.
And I started creating
a whole nother warfare,
a whole nother battle started becoming
them. I was like, oh, hang on a second.
Goggins you have these tools
that he had these tools.
Your life was basically the perfect,
the perfect grounds for training for
where you need to go in your life.
All the beatings, all the, all
the bullying, all the, you know,
you going through a learning disability,
all the struggles.
It was the absolute perfect training
ground for you to go to where you need to
go. And that's how I started looking at
my life versus woe is me. Poopy pants.
Kick a rock down the street mentality.
It was na God.
This hooked you right the fuck up.
He looked you right up man,
with the perfect place you are training
for the first 18 1920 so you were
training for this stuff,
man.
You got the advantage of everybody else
versus my God, they're so above me.
They came from a great family. Mom and
dad loved them. They didn't have a learn.
Danny's daughter, they
didn't struggle. Nah Man,
you're struggle is what
made you who you are now.
So I started flipping this
into a whole different,
I started being a master of was scared of,
I was get up my mind and I became
literally a master of that mind and that's
what now from now on,
it sets me apart from most people.
I started diving into that.
That is a big part of the stories when
you go over your childhood and you know
your abusive father and then having this
great God that was going to become your
stepdad and then he gets murdered.
It's like right when you're about to get
out of it. Everything looks good, boom.
Then he gets murdered.
It's like these things really did sort
of set you up to start from scratch again
and just go,
okay,
Roger that we start from scratch
and now you have that attitude.
You developed it through all of
these horrible personal experiences,
all the trials and tribulations,
all the evil shit that people try to
do to you that sort of set you up to be
able to deal in a way that
a lot of people can't.
Well, I used to look at my life from a
different vantage point. And when you're,
when you're in all the muck and you just
walk in and muck and walking in muck
and walk in and Muck,
you don't see that.
If you look off to the fucking left of
the muck, there's a sidewalk, brother,
get off, get off of it. You have
your head down looking in this muck.
Once I saw the sidewalk,
got the sidewalk,
I got a little break and I
got different vantage point.
And then from the sidewalk I found
a cliff and I found a mountain.
I got way up high on top of my life and
look back down on it and said, okay,
I gotta figure this out man. I'm not
going anywhere. I'm trying to lie.
I'm starting like,
so when you have a messed up foundation,
I started lying about everything.
I wanted people to like me.
I want it to be accepted in some society
of life, some social society, you know.
And I said, man, this isn't the
right way. I messed up here.
I messed up here and messed up everywhere.
And so I realized the worst thing
that happened to me is I lost myself.
I never had myself and her found myself.
I had no self esteem so I knew through
working out into learning can I it?
It took a lot for me to learn.
Also, I started finding self esteem.
Once I found that that's when doors
started opening up. I started,
I stopped caring about people that
what they thought being judged. Well,
if I say this, if I started right
now or you can make fun of me,
I stopped caring about that
and that's my life start.
It really changed it for me.
Slowly but surely.
That's such an important point where
you're talking about the working out
because a lot of people when
they think about working out,
they thinking of it as being a
physical thing, right? No. Oh
No. I did it for mental. Yeah. People
are say my God, like, no, don't,
don't look at it like I didn't
care about losing weight.
I care about being the fastest person. I
came out. I wasn't making the Olympics.
I won't go into prose.
I could barely read and write.
When I was a junior in high school,
I wasn't going anywhere.
I saw working out as a way for
me to build calluses on my mind.
I a callous over the victim's
mentality. So I watched these movies. I,
you know, I talked about rocky
last time I was out here.
I always equated training to mental
toughening like it was a brutal people
waking up early and do it. All these
things, they look, it looks horrible.
I was like, wow man, I got started
doing that. Not to get better,
bigger and stronger,
but that is what's going to build me.
That looks uncomfortable.
That looks brutal and getting up early.
I don't want to do that.
Some of this long list of things I don't
want to do and through that I found
myself, I started d like, I'm
like, you guys aren't doing
this shit in high school.
Did you guys are getting
up at five o'clock in the
morning running over here and
his golf course. So I started
seeing myself very differently than,
than the average human being.
I was like high on a second.
I have some they don't have and that's
when I start to develop these things
through working out.
It was this great never ending work ethic
and through work ethic I develop self
esteem.
Now is this something that you learned?
Is this something you learn yourself from,
from exercise yourself or is this
something you had read or heard about?
Like what made you equate this,
doing this and doing these difficult
things physically to mental toughness to
being, this is the discipline that you
need in order to get your life out of the
situation you're in.
So
read anything. You know, I, I
could barely read, you know,
so I wasn't reading back then.
I just saw,
I watched a lot of movies and I was
really big into visualization and um,
I always equated working out to
struggle and I struggled my whole life,
but I ran from it. So I
started realizing, man,
I got to start facing the struggle and I
got be mentally strong for the struggle.
So that's why I started counting.
Coming up with like I,
I'm training for life mentally.
I'm training for life.
I'm not training for like to,
to lift 400 pounds and I found out on
my own pretty much is that through this,
through through discipline, through
self discipline, through repetition,
do tons of repetition of the same thing
that you don't want to do. And that's it.
And that's the key thing through
repetition of things you don't want to do.
You develop mental,
like like an armor for your mind start
to arm or your mind. I was like, okay,
we suffer, we suffer every day. It's what
we do. We do stuff that sucks every day.
So then when the suck stuff comes,
you're ready for it.
And that's how it started coming up.
You know?
I just started being very uncomfortable
now. It's like a, just a way of life.
It's a crazy thing to figure out though.
It's like the,
you figured it out and you didn't
just figured it out. You embraced it.
Like when you were talking about
your senior year of high school,
when you talking about your, your
mirror being your accountability mirror.
Like you had a radical shift.
Like you just decided to
not be a fucking loser.
And to start tightening up and start
holding yourself accountable and,
and get ready for things.
So I had this my whole life.
I mean,
I don't know if people believe in God or
what, I don't care what you believe in.
There's been this
unrelenting voice in my head.
We all have this voice is
the right or wrong voice.
And a lot of times that voice guides us
into comfort and my voice got it mean to
comfort a lot. But I had this other
voice to her my whole life saying,
hey motherfucker, what are you doing?
Nah Man, we gotta go over here.
We'll go over here to,
to that rock pile over in a fucking
corner where nobody's at. That's,
that's where victory is at.
We're over in that corner.
So this voice was giving me all
these answers. Not I wouldn't,
real smart kid growing up,
but I had this crazy voice in my head
saying over there is where the fucking
answers are and I will listen to it.
Cause over there was pain over there.
It was me looking in the mirror over
there was me being accountable for all
these things I went through my life
in though people put them on me.
It's now mine to own. And I didn't
want to go over there by myself,
but I had to in his voice was guiding me.
There is God,
whatever you wanna call it. Um, but
that's what, that's what it was in me.
Do you think that's just what you eat
when you separate yourself from your ego
and what,
what you were your insecurities and all
you like if you were giving yourself
advice, you would say that's
what the thing is to do.
So do you think that's what it was?
Like your subconscious or the Oh,
you stripped away from all the bullshit
when he couldn't lie to yourself.
Cause it's a voice in your head.
Exactly it, that's exactly it. Because
it knew, it knew I was a character.
I was trying to find
myself do a character.
I was making different hairstyles
and sagging my pants and I was off.
I was off, man. I was, I was a
clown. I was a clown. And I was like,
this is not, this is not
what you're supposed to be
in life, man. And it's ugly.
When you look in that dirty mirror and
you're trying to do a new hairstyle to go
to school.
You know,
I had the hairstyle one time
where I shaved the top of my head.
You know how old men had the
hair leaving their hit? Yeah.
So I went to school with hair on the side
of my head and in my back and I shaved
the whole top of my head. I just, I would
to school like that, you know? And then I,
I'd had like what, what did
the kids say? I want to,
I don't remember what they said, but it
was, I was just a funny dude, you know?
So that was my thing. I was the
funny dude that came into school,
like criss cross came out when I was in
high school, so my pants were backwards.
I see.
No,
I don't have a pass backwards sag down
past my ass crack short term backwards
with a toothbrush in my
mouth with the reverse park.
Reverse part is your head is shaved
and you have some hair on top.
Just a little piece of hair versus
like a like a part two hair.
The part was on a bald head,
so it was this.
I was sitting at home instead of studying
I would think about what can I do to
impress them mother fucker at school.
Why and that became my life and that is,
it's a long road to hoe to get to the
guy who says now you don't ever smile on
any podcasts. Look so serious.
I look at that shit. I'm like,
you motherfuckers have no idea who I am.
Who were where I've come
from to get here today.
You could have probably
been an entertainer like you
probably because you were
doing all that kind of shit. It has some
jokes. Joe, I got some jokes that you do.
So what people read in this book can
hurt me. It's a sad story. It's a story.
It's a tragic story.
It's a story that made me who end the
day but you got the morning laugh at
yourself too. Once you, once you
go through that shit are now,
so there's a lot of parts in, there was
lot me against a lot of white people,
you know, and I have a routine that I
won't do, so people who hire me to speak,
I'm not going to do the routine. I often
do it sometimes. And think about it,
I was at 36 black guy to go
through seal training. Okay.
Now how many people out of probably
looking at probably 1112 uh,
to, to, to make it through
probably 13,000 seals.
I'll probably the 36 I was a 36
black out and make it through.
He never since like did
like the 1940s you know,
you're looking at almost 70 years. Wow.
Yeah. So you know, you know, you know,
do the math on that.
So there's not a lot of black guys and
so I take that and I make a nice comedy
skit out of that Shit.
You know, like, like,
like the first time they tied me up and
threw me, it's called drown proofing.
So I'm negative, buoyant as
hill, you know, me too. Oh,
related to that big time. Yes.
You only a few white boys, man, are
there negative boy and that's hard.
So matching them,
getting your hands and feet,
Tonya asks up and throwing the
fucking water and say swim. Ah,
it was like throwing a cat in the
water with fucking brick on him.
So I was just losing my fucking mind.
So if somebody just had to get over,
you know, and I, and I, and I found humor.
I found humor in my suffering. I was like,
motherfucker, what are you doing out here?
Goggins like, this is crazy. Like you're,
you're literally trying
to reinvent the wheel.
But I was trying to reinvent my mind.
I was trying to reinvent my mind and I
used every single tactic possible to do
that. I didn't want to live, you know,
live in this world where I was
a fake human being anymore.
And I was tired of blaming everybody
for where I was at. My Dad beat me.
This happened. I mean, my
dad ran prostitutes. Man.
My Dad literally snatched the soul out
of my mom. Like my mom is still balanced.
Like after my mom left my dad and this
one I'm talking about in the book,
she got married three times for
a total of six months, you know,
and I'll go there and I'm not even
talking about the guy she married.
So this woman was, she, she's
beautiful. She's, she's so
smart. All this stuff, man.
This guy literally
stripped her Soloway and I,
and I was a young kid watching it and
I had no soul to begin with in my,
and my brother, he has a story that
he could write eight books, you know,
my dad has came through and this
washed, it's all clean. So to, to,
to come still around. He died about
four years ago, four or five years,
if not for sure. I didn't go to
the funeral, but I forgave him.
So I saw my dad through an eight year
old's I. So, so we left and Jose,
and then at 22 I went back to see him
through a grown man's eyes and he was the
same person I remembered, but I
had to, you can't live with hate.
You cannot move forward.
As much as that guy tried to ruin all
of our lives, that's where I came from.
I had to figure out the origin
of where I started from.
So when I was going back through
my latch on to fix who I am,
the fucked up person,
I was like,
if your knee hurts is usually not your
fucking knee that's hurting is something
else man. Like it could be a tight quad,
it could be the right leg, his left leg,
you got to funnel to Aurizon over.
All this shit began and it was him.
So I had to go back to
where, you know, my,
my roots in the origin of all of this
happened in this hard to do that.
Did you make peace with them?
I'm a big piece with,
so we didn't have a peaceful
conversation. We, you know, we,
we left very good animal. He's
a, he's a, he's a vicious man.
He was a vicious man.
I mean mid evil motherfucker.
So I had become a medieval
motherfucker at that time.
I was 22 when I was a big boy and so I
was no longer the guy who was afraid it
was now like, Hey, I want
to kill you type of shit.
And we were sitting at Denny's after an
all night skate or whatever the hell no,
he owned bars and skating rinks,
shit that,
and so we were sitting down and we kinda
got into it and I was kind of left and,
but I had to make peace with it in myself.
I could not hold onto that hate cause
hold onto that hate was half the reason
why I kept falling into the
same pattern of failing.
I had to get out to start
dumping off some baggage,
had to start figuring out me through
him and that's all he was there for.
He was the origin. I had to figure
him out. I forgot why he was so evil.
It to my mom, to me and my brother
and I to start studying him.
Like a lot of people have situations
where someone does something and we all
attack that person. Like, like on the
media, if someone does something wrong,
everybody now is fucking perfect and we
now judge this guy. I don't judge them,
I don't judge anybody. What
I do is I started studying
them. Why did they do that?
Not in a judging way.
I want to learn from you and what'd you
get out of your dad? I got there. He was,
he grew up rough. He had,
he was very insecure,
had a lot of kids and his insecurities
just trickled over on to us.
So yeah, he jacked us up real
good but he never fixed himself.
So if you never fix yourself, the next
person in line is going to get the wrath.
And we were next in line, you know,
his, his first wife, you know,
killed herself or whatever
happened and you know,
got burned up in a house or something.
If some craziness and has lost stuff that
goes on there that I didn't put in the
book because I don't feel like going to
court, you know? But, um, yeah. This, uh,
it was,
it was law stuff.